[Música]
hablamos de salud directa américa ya
está conmigo en el estudio en más
romeros a la mara bienvenida feliz
inicio de semana vamos a hablar de la
farmacéutica pfiezer que anunció su
pastilla contra el kobe 19 que podría
reducir hasta un 89 por ciento el riesgo
grave de kuyt en pacientes contagiados
marc que sabemos de esta noticia pues el
titular que venimos repitiendo desde el
sábado al final es lo que tú ya dices no
ese 89 por ciento pero para saber mejor
de qué estamos hablando vamos a dar una
mirada más cercana a estos estudios que
ha publicado la compañía todavía no
están revisados por pares es sólo
información de la farmacéutica pfiezer y
lo que sabemos también es que este
estudio se hizo sólo con personas con
riesgo de tener como 19 grave que no
estaban vacunadas juntando dos grupos de
estudio que hicieron donde se aplicaba
el tratamiento en días distintos lo que
sabemos es que en el grupo de unas mil
personas que recibió el tratamiento 9
fueron hospitalizadas y ninguna resultó
muerta por kobe 19 mientras que en el
grupo también de unas 1000 personas que
recibió placebo es decir que no fue
tratada en ese caso el 68 fueron las
hospitalizadas y 10 y siete murieron
entonces para interpretar todos estos
datos del estudio the fighter iv de esta
nueva pastilla estamos con el doctor
carlos de eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia muy buenos días doctor cada
lunes gracias por estar con nosotros
cuéntenos cómo podemos interpretar estos
datos de la compañía y es demasiado
temprano para estar haciendo cantos de
victoria como como hemos estado haciendo
hasta ahora
son buenas noticias está pendiente por
evaluar este trabajo por pares
académicos pero lo que significa es que
se encuentran tratamientos efectivos
antivirales y eso hace que los pacientes
ya no hospitalizados sino ambulatorios
al recibir el medicamento impide la
progresión de la enfermedad sin duda es
una buena noticia es muy buena noticia
pero hay que tomarlo con cautela y
esperar la evaluación y esto es un
estudio solamente en mil pacientes
esperemos la eficacia que se miren
millones de pacientes cuando se inicie
esto está también hola doctor gusto
saludarlo feliz lunes feliz inicio de
semana entonces yo le pregunto cómo
funciona este medicamento de pfizer
contra el cob en 19
raúl es muy interesante porque los virus
utilizan unas enzimas unas para
replicarse y otras para madurar se este
medicamento que es un inhibidor de
proteasa impide la maduración del virus
y al impedir la maduración del virus el
virus se hace en efectivo para infectar
a otras células este mecanismo es un
mecanismo muy novedoso se ha usado en
otros virus como el de vih como el de la
hepatitis y se utilizó en este virus y
se lograron tratamientos efectivos para
controlar la replicación un doctor
estaba hablando precisamente del vih y
es que este medicamento se administra el
the fighter me refiero se está
administrando con ritonavir que es un
antirretroviral también que se usa para
para combatir el vih en pacientes
contagiados porque porque se combinan
estos dos medicamentos
el rito nair es un medicamento que se
usó como antinatural hace muchos años
pero lo que se encontró era que
potenciaban los otros medicamentos
porque miren el metabolismo entonces el
recto nadie es una co formulación que
permite la mayor biodisponibilidad la
mayor cantidad del medicamento antiviral
y grecia efectivo esta mezcla no es
porque el ritonavir actúe sino porque el
red ritonavir aumenta los niveles del
antiviral y hace que sea más efectivo y
dure mucho más tiempo en la sangre y
pueda ser efectivo para replicar la
inhibir la reputación picada ahora todos
recordamos también que el laboratorio
américas anunció iba a estar sacando su
píldora contra el hobbit 19 cuál es la
diferencia entre merck y pfizer
en los medicamentos de fase del nivel de
la proteasa la maduración y medicamento
médico inhibe la replicación viral este
también eso me encantó supremamente
interesante porque lea un ladrillo falso
para que no pueda construir en la pared
digamos del virus para que no pueda
hacer su construcción su replicación
este otro mecanismo es un mecanismo que
también impide la replicación viral que
ha demostrado desenlace estricto
satisfactorios entonces tenemos en un
mismo virus dos sitios distintos
todos medicamentos distintos y una buena
efectividad son buenas noticias pues
buenas noticias son las que necesitamos
también para la lucha contra esta
pandemia que recordemos que hoy estamos
a punto de sobrepasar los 250 millones
de contagios por condición acumulados en
el mundo que impacto entonces pueden
tener estos nuevos medicamentos ambos en
este caso sin hacer diferencias en esta
lucha contra la pandemia
son parte del rompecabezas recordemos
que las vacunas son preventivas y éstas
serían cura y vaso de tratamiento
terapéutica llamamos los médicos dentro
del argumento dentro de lo que se
necesita para controlar una enfermedad
zenit a la prevención la identificación
y el diagnóstico y tratamientos
efectivos con estos nuevos actores
ya estaríamos completando ese
rompecabezas para colocar y a una
pandemia pero no a la enfermedad la
enfermedad va a continuar siendo
endémica y pero vamos a terminar esta
expansión y la mortalidad va a ser mucho
más reducida y obviamente es una gran
noticia para nosotros tener estos
elementos terapéuticos actualmente pues
el doctor muchas gracias como siempre
por toda la información y por la
interpretación de estos datos en más
profundidad que nos ayudan a todos a
entender qué está pasando con la
pandemia de kobe 19